Générique
...
- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à
tous et bienvenue.
Nous revenons sur l'actualité de
la semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Cette semaine,
nous accueillons Arthur Delaporte,
député socialiste du Calvados.
Vous avez été élu en juin dernier.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'était la
dernière semaine des travaux
parlementaires avant la trêve
hivernale.
Depuis le mois de juillet, le
gouvernement a fait voter 12
textes en s'appuyant à la fois sur
les députés de droite, mais aussi
sur le Sénat.
On fera le bilan de cette session.
A la rentrée, un dossier explosif
va attendre les députés et les
sénateurs, celui des retraites.
Emmanuel Macron va présenter les
grandes lignes de sa réforme des
retraites en janvier.
L'autre texte chaud du début
d'année, ce sera le projet de loi
sur l'immigration qui prévoit de
régulariser les travailleurs
sans-papiers. Avant la présentation
du texte,
les sénateurs ont exprimé leur
position lors d'un débat ce mardi.
- Kathia Gilder: Les travaux
parlementaires vont être
suspendus, l'occasion pour nous de
faire un petit bilan.
Depuis l'élection de la nouvelle
Assemblée, 12 textes ont été votés
par le Parlement et ce malgré
l'absence de majorité.
L'Exécutif a donc trouvé des
alliés pour faire adopter ces
réformes.
- Si le marathon budgétaire a
donné lieu à une succession de
49.3 et de motions de censure, pas
de paralysie au Parlement depuis
juillet.
12 textes ont été adoptés.
- Pour, 210. Contre, 140.
L'Assemblée nationale a adopté.
- Pour 187 contre 60.
- L'Assemblée a adopté.
- Pour cela, plusieurs stratégies:
compter sur le Sénat, jugé plus
constructif et moins politique
qu'une Assemblée en ébullition.
Le gouvernement parie aussi sur la
bonne volonté des sénateurs, de
droite notamment, lors des
commissions mixtes paritaires pour
trouver un accord entre les deux
chambres.
Le gouvernement a aussi cherché à
convaincre des groupes
d'oppositions à l'Assemblée.
Jusqu'à présent, surtout la droite,
comme pour la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ou la loi de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur.
La droite en renfort de la
majorité, mais sur les énergies
renouvelables, c'est bien sur la
gauche que compte l'Exécutif.
Autre méthode nouvelle dans la
majorité: se montrer ouverte sur
des textes d'autres groupes
politiques comme la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle visant le
droit à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse portée par les
Insoumis.
- Le texte que nous nous apprêtons
à voter avec la plus large
majorité, je l'espère,
devient le texte de notre Assemblée.
Il doit toutes et tous nous
réunir.
- Une Assemblée qui avance entre
49.3 et motions de censure.
Une nuance, toutefois: pour ne pas
être mis en minorité, la majorité
a dû faire de l'obstruction,
comme sur la réintégration des
soignants non-vaccinés.
Ce sont deux textes
particulièrement sensibles qui
attendent le gouvernement et les
parlementaires à la rentrée 2023:
les retraites et l'immigration.
- Kathia Gilder: Arthur Delaporte,
finalement, sans majorité absolue,
12 textes ont été votés.
Cela montre que l'exécutif n'est
pas si affaibli que ça.
- Arthur Delaporte: Ca montre
surtout qu'il a réussi à se
trouver un allié: la droite.
Sur chacun des textes, il a pu
compter sur l'appui des députés LR
qui n'ont pas spécialement envie
d'être vus comme des obstructeurs,
mais qui se retrouvent complices
au soutien du gouvernement.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est la force de
la majorité, pour vous?
- Arthur Delaporte: C'est une
évidence, quand je pense que la
plupart de mes collègues LR
l'assument.
Ils sont dans une logique où ils
sont les supplétifs d'une majorité
qui est minoritaire et qui a
besoin d'aller chercher des
soutiens.
Ca conduit à des textes qui sont
toujours plus à droite.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le
gouvernement s'appuie sur la
majorité de droite sénatoriale
pour faire voter certains textes
comme le projet de loi
d'orientation et programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur,
ou la réforme de l'assurance
chômage.
Vous dites que c'est une alliance
entre le gouvernement et la droite
qui ne dit pas son nom?
- Arthur Delaporte: J'étais dans
la commission mixte paritaire qui
a fabriqué le texte actuel de
l'assurance chômage.
Il y avait des députés et des
sénateurs.
LR était minoritaire et
En Marche à l'Assemblée.
J'avais l'impression d'assister à
un échange de bonnes camaraderies.
J'avais l'impression de voir se
dégrader les droits des chômeurs
au fur et à mesure par la
philosophie de cette réforme,
qui consistait à taper
encore plus sur les chômeurs.
LR a introduit une présomption de
démission, d'abandon de poste.
Ce sont des choses inédites dans
le droit.
Ce sera contesté, à mon avis,
devant les tribunaux car c'est
assez choquant.
C'est l'apport des LR,
d'avoir réussi à durcir des textes
qui étaient déjà anti-sociaux.
- Kathia Gilder: Elisabeth Borne a
utilisé pas moins de 10 fois
l'article 49.3 de la Constitution
pour faire passer en force les
budgets, et notamment une baisse
d'impôts de 8 milliards d'euros
sur les entreprises, sans l'accord
du Parlement.
Vous en dites quoi?
- Arthur Delaporte: Je ne vais pas
me féliciter de cette situation.
Des députés n'ont pas été
consultés sur des dépenses
fondamentales pour l'équilibre de
la nation.
On aurait bien aimé parler du
budget de l'éducation, de la
police ou du budget général de
l'Etat.
8 milliards d'euros ont été
supprimés comme ça.
C'est historique.
C'est ce qu'ont rappelé mes
collègues également.
On a un budget qui est de 300
milliards.
Vous avez presque 2% du budget de
l'Etat qui est supprimé sans
débats, sans que les parlementaires
aient pu échanger sur ce point.
J'espère que les Françaises
et les Français sont aussi choqués
que nous.
Ca révèle que ce gouvernement, qui
disait vouloir construire une
nouvelle méthode sur le compromis,
est surtout un gouvernement
dirigiste qui n'écoute pas et ne
cherche pas à faire vivre le débat
dans le Parlement.
On peut toujours comprendre qu'ils
n'ont pas de majorité, mais ce
n'est pas que ça.
Au début, il y a eu un soir où on
venait de débattre d'une motion de
censure sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale,
zéro seconde après ce débat,
on utilise le 49.3.
La 4e partie du projet de loi
de la Sécurité sociale a
été adoptée sans qu'on ait pu en
discuter.
- Alexandre Poussart: L'affaire
Adrien Quatennens a également
marqué ce début de session
parlementaire et a fragilisé la
NUPES.
Le député Insoumis a reconnu avoir
giflé sa femme et il a été
condamné à quatre mois de prison
avec sursis.
Il a été suspendu temporairement
de son groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Il a dit qu'il souhaitait revenir
en janvier dans l'hémicycle en
tant que député.
Comprenez-vous son souhait de
revenir?
- Arthur Delaporte: Non. Je ne le
comprends pas.
Je trouve que les mots qu'il a
employés étaient particulièrement
dérangeants.
J'ai été choqué de ce déballage.
Je vois qu'il n'a pas compris ce
qu'il s'est passé dans son cas
personnel et, plus largement, en
France.
Aujourd'hui, quand on est
responsable d'un parti politique
comme La France Insoumise qui se
revendique féministe, quand on est
dans un accord avec des partis
comme le Parti Socialiste qui
exige une exemplarité, quand on
est condamné à une peine de prison
-avec sursis- et qu'on revient en
disant: "Circulez, j'ai compris mais
je ne suis pas responsable",
Ce n'est pas le sujet.
Le sujet est judiciaire, mais
aussi politique, éthique et
morale.
Là, j'ai trouvé que le
comportement d'Adrien Quatennens
était assez indécent et je suis
assez mal à l'aise sur cette
situation.
Je me réjouis de la position de La
France Insoumise, même si elle
aurait pu être plus dure.
Je pense qu'on reviendra sur
l'exclusion temporaire.
J'aurais souhaité une exclusion
définitive.
On en rediscutera.
Je suis assez mal à l'aise.
- Kathia Gilder: Le grand sujet de
la rentrée, ce sera celui de la
retraite.
Emmanuel Macron va présenter sa
réforme le 10 janvier.
En attendant, Elisabeth Borne
consulte à tout-va.
Qui pense quoi et que dit le
gouvernement ?
Voici un florilège de
réactions.
-Elisabeth Borne : Quelles que
soient nos différences, pour sauver
notre système de retraite par
répartition, nous restons ouverts,
déterminés à dialoguer, à construire
et à agir.
- J'ai pu lui présenter ce
qu'une majorité sénatoriale vote
depuis plusieurs années,
c'est une réforme très équilibrée
et juste
avec un mélange de report de
l'âge légal progressivement
et une
accélération de la réforme Touraine.
- Une réforme, c'est quand on
améliore les conditions de vie des
gens.
Ce n'est pas ça.
Cette réforme est imposée par le
gouvernement et vise à nous faire
travailler plus longtemps.
Le gouvernement impose un débat
sur un tout petit point.
Ca va creuser les inégalités et
faire que de plus en plus de
personnes ne vont pas pouvoir
profiter des meilleures années de
la retraite.
C'est inadmissible et, dans un
contexte de crise, encore plus.
- Kathia Gilder: Elisabeth Borne
s'est dite ouvert aux propositions.
Elle a dit devant la représentation
nationale. Est-ce que vous, au Parti
Socialiste vous êtes d'accord pour
faire des propositions ?
- Arthur Delaporte: Cette nouvelle
méthode est une forme d'hypocrisie
permanente.
On sait très bien qu'Elisabeth
Borne est ouverte, mais en même
temps, elle refuse de négocier sur
le report de l'âge légal.
Elle se dit ouverte, en même temps,
elle nous dit qu'elle considère que
le régime de retraite doit être
réformé. Ce n'est pas nécessaire.
Cette ouverture est une ouverture
de façade.
Il y a des risques qui sont
économiques, sur cette réforme.
Il y a aussi des risques sociaux.
Ce n'est évoqué non plus.
On ne peut
jamais en discuter.
Je considère qu'on a un gouvernement
qui fait la sourde oreille, surtout
à gauche, et qui cherche à allier
LR à sa politique.
Sur les retraites, j'ai l'impression
que ce ne sera pas aussi simple que
sur le reste. Les députés LR
ont l'air d'être aussi sensibles
à l'injustice profonde de
cette réforme.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cette réforme
des retraites va-t-elle être le
grand combat de la gauche et des
syndicats?
- Arthur Delaporte: Nous sommes
pleinement mobilisés.
Vous projetiez
des images d'une conférence de
presse de mercredi dernier avec
l'ensemble des groupes politiques de
la gauche à l'Assemblée et au Sénat.
Ca montre notre unité collective
face à tout recul de l'âge
légal à la retraite.
Ca montre aussi notre mobilisation
aux côtés des syndicats. On a dit:
"Donnez-nous votre date, nous serons
avec vous, nous sommes à vos côtés
pour que la mobilisation sociale
face au refus des Français soit la
plus importante possible".
- Kathia Gilder: Vous aviez dit que
les comptes n'étaient pas si en
déficit que ça. Vous avez vu le
rapport d'orientation des retraites.
Le gouvernement dit il y a une
urgence à réformer le système des
retraites. Vous, que proposez-vous
pour redresser les comptes?
- Arthur Delaporte: Ce n'est pas
vrai. Les comptes sont
excédentaires. 900 millions d'euros.
Ce sont les chiffres généraux. Le
déficit du régime des retraites est
à horizon 2027.
Que disent les spécialistes ? C'est
qu'on ne réforme pas un budget parce
qu'il est déficitaire dans cinq ans.
Les retraites sont pour toute une
vie. Il faut réformer à horizon 2050
ou 2070. Qu'est-ce qu'on voit ?
Ca s'équilibre et on est sur des
déficits qui sont assez légers. Même
en 2027, entre 0,8 et 1 %. Il n'y a
pas de nécessité immédiate de
réformer.
Si on se dit qu'il faut, parce qu'on
a les effets d'augmentation de
dépenses liées à la génération des
baby-boomers,
on peut avoir un besoin de
financement, mais il n'y a pas
absolument besoin de repousser l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite. Il y
a 12 milliards d'euros à trouver.
Vous évoquez une suppression d'un
impôt à 8 milliards d'euros. D'un
côté, on supprime un impôt sur les
entreprises de 8 milliards d'euros,
et de l'autre, on fait travailler
les Français deux ou trois ans de
plus.
Vous vous rendez compte de
l'injustice ? On n'a pas besoin
d'aller chercher de l'argent sur la
vie des Français et des Françaises.
Ce qui se passe quand on repousse
l'âge légal de la retraite, c'est
que l'on renforce les inégalités.
Entre les 5% les plus pauvres et
les 5% les plus riches,
il y a 13 ans de différence
d'espérance de vie. Les travailleurs
les plus pauvres ont une espérance
de vie qui dépasse à peine l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite.
On veut supprimer le droit à la
retraite des plus pauvres, on ne
peut pas l'accepter. Ce sera une
ligne rouge. C'est inacceptable.
12 milliards d'euros, ce n'est pas
grand-chose.
Par rapport au budget total des
retraites, ce n'est pas
grand-chose.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous parliez
de l'alliance de la
gauche contre cette réforme
des retraites.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
La France Insoumise qui veut
revenir à la retraite à 60 ans?
- Arthur Delaporte: Le programme sur
lequel je me suis engagé,
c'est un objectif.
La question principale est le
front commun qui englobe les
syndicats et les forces
politiques.
Nous refusons le report de l'âge
légal.
Ce sera l'unique mot d'ordre.
On peut avoir des sujets
d'amélioration.
Il vaut mieux prendre en compte la
pénibilité.
- Kathia Gilder: Pas de retraite à
60 ans pour ne pas fracturer l'union
de la gauche.
- Arthur Delaporte: Nous expliquons
qu'il faut une
prise en compte pour celles et
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt, que la pénibilité soit mieux
reconnue.
L'enjeu est là.
Je le redis: dans notre
opposition, je suis malade, quand
je pense à ce contre quoi nous
allons nous battre.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il va y avoir
le projet loi
immigration qui va faciliter les
expulsions des étrangers
délinquants, et aussi régulariser
les travailleurs sans-papiers dans
les métiers en tension.
Les sénateurs ont donné leur avis
dans l'hémicycle.
- Les sénateurs ont salué la
méthode.
Plusieurs ministres de premier
plan ont été dépêchés dans
l'hémicycle de la chambre haute, à
commencer par Elisabeth Borne.
Elle affirme d'ores et déjà
s'inspirer des travaux du Sénat
pour élaborer son texte.
- Elisabeth Borne: Je sais que nous
partons sur des
fondements solides.
La Haute Assemblée a toujours eu à
coeur de porter des débats d'idées
et de chercher des solutions
communes.
Vous avez aussi, je le sais et j'y
reviendrai, travailler sur la
question migratoire, sur ses
implications et sur les grands
chantiers à mener.
- Le gouvernement veut allier
efficacité, humanité et fermeté.
Il voudrait accélérer les demandes
d'asile pour les faire passer d'un
an à six mois et accélérer les
expulsions d'étrangers menaçant
l'ordre public.
Le gouvernement veut faciliter les
les obligations de quitter le
territoire.
Leur taux d'application est
actuellement très faible.
- Le taux d'exécution des OQTF est
à un niveau de 6,9% au premier
semestre 2022.
On peut discuter de la pertinence
de ce taux, mais nous ne pouvons
que constater un indicateur
constant. Nous exécutions 22% de nos
OQTF en 2012.
3 fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui.
-Les Socialistes restent opposés
au futur projet de loi. Seul point
salué par le chef de file:
la volonté du gouvernement
de créer des
titres de séjour "métiers en
tension" pour faciliter le
recrutement
de travailleurs immigrés.
- Quand on donne le droit au travail
à des personnes protégées par la
France, on l'a vu avec l'Ukraine, ça
marche. Je suis convaincu que
travailler à l'autonomie des
personnes qui arrivent dès qu'elles
arrivent,
c'est nécessaire, même si après,
on doit leur dire qu'ils n'ont pas
la protection.
- Le futur projet de loi
immigration va arriver au Sénat en
mars 2023.
La chambre haute va examiner ce
texte avant l'Assemblée.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que les
députés socialistes pourraient
voter ce texte?
- Arthur Delaporte: Non.
Quand on a eu le débat sur ce sujet,
Gérald Darmanin a commencé en
citant Bainville,
un royaliste nationaliste
et antisémite.
Il n'a pris aucune distance
par rapport aux propos de l'auteur.
J'ai été profondément choqué.
J'ai été aussi rassuré dans mon
opposition, parce que cette
réforme, qui se dit "ferme et
humaine",
cet élément de langage que l'on
entend depuis 1980. Il y a eu 29
lois différentes sur l'immigration.
On a toujours dit: "On est
l'humanité et la fermeté."
Je ne vois que la fermeté et
l'inhumanité.
Quand on voit la manière dont sont
traités les étrangers sans-papiers
par Gérald Darmanin, qui a
produit une circulaire ignoble,
qui considère les personnes
sous OQTF comme des délinquants...
Soyons raisonnables!
Les personnes sous OQTF ne sont
pas tous délinquants.
C'est une minorité.
- Kathia Gilder: Gérald Darmanin dit
qu'il veut mieux expulser et mieux
intégrer.
Il y a notamment l'idée de créer
un titre de séjour pour les
secteurs de la restauration ou
encore de l'hôtellerie.
- Arthur Delaporte: Il n'y a pas
besoin de loi pour cela.
Manuel Valls, en 2012,
a fait une circulaire qui
permettait la régulation
pour motifs économiques.
Rien de nouveau sous le soleil.
On va dans une mesure de bon sens.
Quand je suis en circonscription,
j'ai des personnes qui viennent à ma
permanence,
des étrangers qui sont
aujourd'hui sous OQTF et qui
doivent quitter le territoire mais
qui, pour certains, travaillent
dans les CHU, sont parfois aides à
domicile, ou bien travaillent dans
le bâtiment.
Ces personnes sont utiles à notre
pays.
Elles trouvent un cadre de vie
plus accueillant que dans leur
propre pays.
Par contre, il ne faut pas que cela
soit utilisé pour faire des
étrangers une main-d'oeuvre de
corvée, mais c'est toujours mieux
d'avoir des étrangers en situations
régulières qui sont avec des
contrats de travail et bénéficient
du SMIC que d'avoir du travail au
noir et de l'exploitation de la
misère humaine. C'est inacceptable.
C'est une mesure qui va dans le bon
sens.
Il n'y a pas besoin d'une loi pour
ça.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous parliez
des OQTF. Il n'y a pas un problème,
quand seulement 10% de ces décisions
sont appliquées?
- Arthur Delaporte: Il faut dire 10%
de quoi.
Le nombre d'OQTF a été augmenté de
50% ces dernières années. Pourquoi?
Parce que Gérald Darmanin et
Gérard Collomb ont eu des
consignes données aux préfets.
On leur a dit de ne plus analyser
les dossiers dans le détail.
Il y a aussi la dématérialisation.
On ne voit plus l'étranger comme
un être en chair et en os.
C'est un dossier dématérialisé.
On a donc augmenté le nombre
d'OQTF.
Il y a aussi beaucoup de pays avec
qui on a des contentieux qui
refusent de donner l'autorisation
aux personnes sous OQTF de
revenir, comme l'Algérie.
C'est pour ça qu'on a un faible taux
d'exécution.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous pensez, sur ce
texte,
que le gouvernement peut
utiliser le 49.3 pour faire
passer ce texte en force?
- Artur Delaporte: Si le
gouvernement utilise le 49.3
pour un texte qui n'a aucun
intérêt pour les Françaises
et les Français,
qui fait de la com' sur un enjeu
scandaleux, avec Bainville,
nationaliste, royaliste,
antisémite,
on a un véritable
problème de fond.
Si j'étais gouvernant, je ne
choisirais pas d'utiliser la seule
cartouche que j'ai pour faire
passer un texte pour ça.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va regarder
l'agenda du parlement
pour le début de 2023.
Pour le mois de janvier, il y aura
la présentation de la réforme des
retraites.
Emmanuel Macron va révéler les
grandes lignes.
Le texte va être présenté au
Conseil des ministres fin janvier.
Le mois sera également marqué par
le projet de loi censé accélérer
la construction de réacteurs
nucléaires.
- Kathia Gilder: Le Sénat va aussi
débuter l'examen du projet de
loi immigration
qui va être débattu en mars et
une proposition de loi pour
introduire le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution.
Elle a été votée à la
majorité à l'Assemblée.
Le texte sera examiné par le Sénat,
voté largement à l'Assemblée.
La majorité de droite est plutôt
hostile.
- Alexandre Poussart: Une question
sur le projet de loi qui doit
accélérer la construction de
réacteurs nucléaires.
En cette période de grand froid,
on manque d'énergie électrique.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas la faute
des Socialistes et de Ecologistes
qui ont pris la décision de fermer
la centrale Fessenheim?
- Arthur Delaporte: Ce n'est pas
parce qu'on a fermé la centrale
qu'on est dans une situation de
pénurie d'énergie:
le parc nucléaire est à l'arrêt;
les réacteurs sont en maintenance.
On a une forme de transition
avec une augmentation de la demande
d'électricité, avec de nouvelles
fenêtres de consommation.
Je voudrais vous dire qu'on avait,
cette semaine, à l'Assemblée, un
texte sur les énergies
renouvelables.
L'enjeu est de développer les
panneaux solaires,
le photovoltaïque et l'éolien,
pour pouvoir électrifier
et faire une énergie bas carbone et
peu dangereuse.
La question nucléaire est une
énergie de transition.
Il faut en sortir.
Ce sera à l'horizon 2050.
- Kathia Gilder: On termine
avec un mot. Vous allez faire
l'ordre du jour le 9 février.
Vous déposez un texte sur les
influenceurs.
- Arthur Delaporte: Les influenceurs
sont des personnes qui font de la
pub sur les réseaux sociaux,
connues grâce à la téléréalité.
Ils vendent parfois des "pilules
miracle contre le cancer",
ils font la promotion des paris
sportifs encore de la chirurgie
esthétique.
Ca ne peut plus durer.
Les réseaux sociaux, c'est pas la
loi de la jungle.
Je propose d'interdire un certain
nombre de publicités et de
dire quand c'est de la pub.
Ils ont des avantages en nature,
mais ils ne le disent pas forcément.
Il faudrait le marquer.
- Kathia Gilder: Merci.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est la fin
de ce dernier numéro de l'année
2022.
Merci à tous de nous avoir suivis.